Wow yeah didn't call that so I've
reached the end of broadchurch series
one well handled I think I think is the
the best turn of phrase I can give it
the the killer was surprising but
ultimately they didn't play it out for
the shock of who was they let the the
emotional residents of it ring very true
and I'm sorry I'm kept I'm kind of
emotionally exhausted and yeah I need to
okay so with it turning out to be Joe
would that turning out to be the husband
of Ellie of Ellie Miller one of the
detectives working on it that could have
really felt cheap that could have felt
unjustified but I think they did justify
it well and the whole element of what
his relationship with Danny was also
could have been very cheap it could have
been very very sleazy and and I think
they chose a very good balance because
it makes you uncomfortable definitely
but it's also doesn't cross into that
quite as easily demonized and no I don't
think if the gold isn't any way to make
you sympathize with Joe but it does get
you to understand his head space a
little bit because you know that
what went on between him and Danny feels
wrong add a basic gut
fundamental level and yet he hadn't
taken thing you know aside from the fact
that he killed him hmm
he hadn't taken things to to a physical
degree that you could objectively go you
can't do that but it's just it isn't
wrong this this this isn't good and sort
of coming back around and and and he now
I understood why the whole thing with
Susan and Nigel was was ended cuz
initially I just pegged it as as a red
herring and now it has relevance because
that question that she had that Ellie
asked Susan now gets asked of her by
Beth and rightfully so how could you not
know
and it almost feels like painful karmic
justice that Ellie couldn't possibly
understand how Sudan Susan couldn't have
know what was going on and now people
can't possibly understand how Ellie
didn't know what was going on so there's
there's all that going on mark honestly
gave the MVP performance in this last
episode to me it started early on when
he's just in in Danny's bedroom and he's
he notes you know they're gonna have to
you know take everything out so that it
can be the new baby's room he's just
sitting in there and he goes I don't
want to take it apart and Mark has been
played as a very kind of repressed guy
he doesn't he doesn't wear his heart in
his sleeve certainly he's very reserved
and the scene of him confronting Joe
that was an amazing scene and not just
in terms of the performances which were
great but also in terms of the shooting
because you've got this little square in
this massive metal door that that they
can look at each other through and Mark
is right up to it so it's just doing a
basic cut back and forth between them as
they talk but because mark is right up
to it so when it's looking at him
mark looms so large in that shot cuz he
he takes up more than the the just the
hole in the door and Joe looks so small
because he's so much further back so
like the entire upper half isn't aimed
in this box and the contrast of that
come combined with the performances I
was a really incredible scene and with
[Music]
Hardy huh I finally remember David
Tennant's character's name with Hardy
trying to figure out how to tell Ellie
and very obviously not knowing how to do
it so the only way you can think to do
it is to start to relay the information
through the means of an of an
interrogation in terms of asking her
questions that's the best way seems to
be able to relate to anybody and it's
still not appropriate to the situation
yeah it's funny the they were the show
was a mystery and there was you know the
question of who killed Danny Latimer but
ultimately this is a story about broken
relationships in the secrets
that are kept within those relationships
because it's pretty much across the
board jack the newsagent had a you know
his wife wasn't around anymore but he
had a whole life in history that nobody
in the town knew Joe had this thing
going on with Danny which obviously he'd
been keeping from everybody Susan
Nigel was her son which nobody knew and
he'd been and he hadn't been aware even
of the fact that that he was adopted
Mark was having an affair Hardy talking
about you know his history what having a
Sandy Brook his wife was having an
affair just the it's all broken all the
things all the relationships all the
connections they're all broken none of
them work and sort of seeing that and
seeing the commonality of there's no two
people who are together in this story
who actually know each other it feels
like properly and yeah it's it's it's a
heavy show it's heavy and it's well done
I'm not I'm not gonna rush to see series
two or series three that's not me saying
that I won't see them but I probably
won't do episode by episode reviews show
them because you know I did it I did
this because I needed to fill time so I
could take a vacation but it's been an
interesting journey watching this now
there is gonna be one more video because
and then this one I need to sleep on
before I get to but for you guys that'll
be all the same it'll be out tomorrow
your time you crazy
advanced people of the future
tired can you tell so in any case
there's gonna be one more video coming
off the back of broadchurch and that is
how my having completed this show
impacts my thoughts on Chris Chibnall as
showrunner for Doctor Who because up to
this point my feelings and concerns have
been based pretty much entirely on his
output within the universe of dark room
meaning Doctor Who and Torchwood and
I've had more than a few people tell me
you need to see broadchurch because
that's his best work and I think they're
probably right about that
but I need to sleep on this and think on
it a little bit before I can put down my
thoughts as to how either positively or
negatively having completed this first
series this show impacts my thoughts on
Chibnall
and being the showrunner so that'll wrap
up this one the eighth episode of series
run of broadchurch or just give your
thoughts on series one overall whatever
they may be drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's all
this stuff to do support me on patreon
phone me on Twitter links for all that
and more is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]